leonardo dicaprio and camila marone have
broken up the 47 year old actor and 25
year old model are going their separate
ways after four years of dating a source
confirmed the split to e.t explaining
they've been spending a lot of time
apart this summer and doing their own
things
see i'm romantic in a different way you
know
i'm not exactly like i'll show up with a
new car or
climb up to a room or anything like that
and that romantic young leo went on to
have many high-profile relationships
from giselle boonchin
to bar rafaeli but when it came to his
romance with camila they kept things on
the down-low the pair was first linked
in december 2017 and for years they made
not a single public appearance together
jump to 2020 and leo and camilla finally
made their debut as a couple sitting
together at the oscars but they walked
the carpet separately all i have to say
there's a lot harder jobs in the world
than doing than doing what i do and if
and for the price that i have to pay is
to lose some automate autonomy that's
that's just the way it goes i'd quit if
it was that big of a deal another part
of their relationship that fascinated
fans their 23-year age gap camila was 20
when she began dating leo he turned 43
that year
things are going to be said no matter
what about you and there's nothing
there's no control you can really the
only thing you can sort of control is
you know that i can sort of control is
what i want to do
as an actor you know what i mean where i
want to go with my career but the model
didn't stay quiet when the trolls
attacked
i just
read some of the comments on my
instagram and
[Music]
my god people are so mean
and like full of anger with people that
they know nothing about
and uh
i guess i just hope on this friday that
people learn to
live with a little less hatred leo and
camilla seemingly pushed past what
people had to say and when the pandemic
came in 2020 it only seemed to
strengthen their relationship a source
told et at the time they were very much
in love and camilla's leo's dream girl
what keeps me grounded is uh
you know i'm sure everyone says the same
thing when they get asked that question
but the truth is it is it is my friends
and family and being able to joke around
and have a sense of humor about
everything
and that that kind of that world and be
able being able to have the sanctity of
people that you know and love and trust
around you
really does make you safe feel safe
in this sort of environment because it
is kind of insane sometimes and camila
an actress who grew up with al pacino as
her stepdad also knows a thing or two
about navigating life in the spotlight i
was fortunate in the sense that i grew
up in hollywood so i feel like i i saw a
lot of that and i was exposed to that at
a very young age but
i didn't feel overwhelmed when i got
into this industry because my parents
were actors i grew up in hollywood so so
i i was very exposed to it more so than
if i had come from a different country
or a small town so i feel that i got a
little bit of an extra foot in the door
because i i knew what i was getting
myself into
[Music]
you